[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Michel midoro bonsoir
bonsoir On commence ces infos du jour
avec l'hommage national rendu aux 42
victimes françaises suite à l'assaut du
Hamas le 7 octobre dernier Emmanuel
Macron a présidé la cérémonie aux
Invalides ce matin d'autres cérémonies
se sont aussi tenues un peu partout en
France comme à Montini le Bretonneux
effectivement Mathilde la commune de
montinau Bretonneux a tenu sa cérémonie
dans la la salle du conseil municipale
de l'Hôtel de Ville un moment de
recueillement avec un discours de
rassemblement de paix et de fraternité
s'en est suivi une minute de silence
avant une Marseillaise une cquantaine de
personnes étaient présentes parmi elles
le Rabin de 5 ans en iveline Mandel
nisambum on l'écoute c'est bien sûr le
la mémoire des victime mais surtout
c'est combattre l'antisémitisme et que
cette fois-ci sera vraiment le plus
jamais c'est-à-dire accepter l'autre et
être pour une fois tous ensemble en pays
en harmonie on parle en Israël de
plusieurs centaines de personnes qui se
sont cet après-midi réunies au même
moment où le président de la République
faisait son hommage aux Invalides
c'est-à-dire que ça a été pris pas
seulement bien pris se sentir soutenu
dans un même combat une information qui
vient de nous parvenir à présent Michell
d'après Le Parisien le Conseil des
ministres du jour a acté le départ du du
préfet des Yvelines Jean-Jacques Brau
oui Mathilde Jean-Jacques Brau quittera
ses fonctions à la préfecture du
département le 2 mars prochain arrivé en
avril 2018 le haut fonctionnaire de 68
ans aura notamment géré la crise
sanitaire l'assassinat de Samuel pati ou
encore la préparation des Jeux
Olympiques dans les Yvelines en connait
son remplaçant il s'agit de Frédéric
rose actuel conseiller à la sécurité du
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron on poursuit ces infos du jour
avec le Festival du film francophone
pour la jeunesse qui débute aujourd'hui
au Mureau jusqu'au 13 février débute la
3e édition de ce rendez-vous sur le 7e
arm mtant à l'honneur des films
francophones venus du monde entier pour
la sélection des films adaptés aux
enfants jusqu'à 12 ans comme Marinette
de Virginie verrier ou la vie de ma mère
de Julien à Carpentier ce samedi 10
février des ateliers seront proposés au
public autour du doublage de voix du
montage et du trucage une belle occasion
de découvrir tous les secrets de la
réalisation des techniques du cinéma on
regarde tout de suite un extrait de la
bande annonce d'un des films
sélectionnés pour ce festival je suis
trop fan je peux prendon celle-ci euh
non juste avec
diva
arrête je veux juste qu'on fasse
connaissance il y a quoi dégage avec ton
chuso je ne voyage pas en se madame je
vous le dis pour la 1è fois notre chat
est en
[Musique]
sécurite on parle des chiens et des
chats Mikel on continue avec une
information insolite la centrale canine
l'organisme coordonnant le milieu du
chien en France a dévoilé le top 3 des
chiens préféré des Français en île-de-
France et le chouchou des Franciliens
c'est le Stafford bulterrier avec
871 naissance enregistré au Livre des
Origines Françaises en 2023 il est aussi
appelé stffi c'est un molose de petite
taille parfois victime des idées reçues
ce n'est pas un chien catégorisé pas
obligatoire de lui faire porter une
musolière dans les espaces publics à la
deuxememe place on retrouve le golden
retriever le cavalier king charles
complète le podium bien merci beaucoup m
je suis très fan du cavalier king
charles personnellement très bien moi je
suis plutôt border colis merci beaucoup
Michel pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une image ou une information qui
vous a marqué n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 7 news